l'aude blanchemaison merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur ft france alors on le
disait l'italie a reçu l'aide de la
russie dans la forme d'une équipe de
médecins et le matériel
c'est un signe fort comment comprendre
je crois que les autorités italiennes se
sont rendus compte assez tôt au mois de
mars qu'elle risquait de perdre le
contrôle de la situation et le premier
ministre monsieur nous était conté est
adressé à plusieurs interlocuteurs et
finalement d'ailleurs le 21 mars il a eu
la demie routine au téléphone et lui a
demandé son aide et vladimir poutine
s'est engagé à fournir à fournir cette
aide elle est arrivée très rapidement à
partir du lendemain
une quinzaine d'avions et liu xin gros
porteurs sont venus apporter le matériel
les camions mais le matériel aussi le
médical et puis il et les médecins les
spécialistes qui accompagne alors je
crois que ça arrange évidemment très
grand service à al ala l'italie parce
que la situation est très très difficile
bien sûr il ya d'autres pays qui eux
aussi ont entrepris d'aider l'italie où
l'avait dit tout à l'heure le cuba la
chine
peut-être que l'italie n'est pas
mécontente d'équilibré avec la russie
d'ailleurs la france qui n'a pas fait
beaucoup de bruit à à livrer un milliard
de 1 million par dont un million de
masques de masquer le 21 mars
précisément sur l'aéroport de fiumicino
à rome
mais évidemment à la france étant
ensuite en angle de masques n'a pas pu
poursuivre ce genre ce genre de
fournitures alors je pense que
actuellement la situation fait que la
coopération marche très bien entre les
équipes russes et l'équipe italienne
alors la russie venus en aide également
aux états unis avez vous été surpris par
son geste de vladimir poutine vis-à-vis
des américains dans ce contexte de lutte
contre le coronavirus moi non mais mes
amis oui vous savez qu'aujourd'hui nous
sommes le 1er avril
et quand j'ai parlé de ça ce matin à
certains de mes amis ils ont cru que
je me moquais d'eux que ce que c'est une
plaisanterie de mauvais goût
donc moi je suis pas surpris parce que
bien sûr la dîmière poutine et priant
les etats-unis se parlent se parlent
très régulièrement et que la l'évolution
de la delà de la pandémie étant
tellement rapide aux états unis par
ailleurs les états unis ayant des
responsabilités globales notamment dans
le monde en matière économique il est
logique que le panier en trompette
président poutine en ai parlé et qu'il
en avait parlé pour la dernière fois je
crois que c'était lundi donc avant-hier
le président trump a indiqué hier dans
une de ces innombrables conférences de
presse il avait évoqué beaucoup de
sujets avec le président poutine il
avait aussi parlé un petit peu
auparavant au prince héritier d'arabie
saoudite peut-être pour parler un peu et
du pétrole mais il a évidemment parlé du
développement de la de la pandémie est
aussi de ce qu'il faudrait faire après
et de ce qui convenait de faire pour
éviter à un effondrement économique est
là dessus bien sûr ils ont décidé le
prétend poutine et le pays entre up de
poursuivre la coopération présent
poutine a proposé d'envoyer un avion
avec une aide médicale et préfère en
train a accepté cette allure de violence
symbolique parce que la quantité des
deux n'est pas tellement importante mais
je crois qu'il est important de marquer
par cette symbolique il y à une
coopération entre les états unis et la
russie
alors on en parlait également ankara a
aussi envoyé du matériel à l'espagne et
l'italie à l'allemagne et la france ont
su utiliser un ce texte le mécanisme
européen qui permet de commercer avec
l'iran pour envoyer là aussi de l'aide
humanitaire la coopération
internationale finalement il tourna à
plein régime en ce moment non bah je
crois qu'elle est appelée à se
développer
ce n'est qu'à ce n'est qu'un début et je
pense que après la crise faudra
effectivement faire des réformes qui
permettront dans ces domaines d'avoir
des systèmes de coopération
internationale beaucoup plus
performant alors en effet vous l'avez
dit la turquie a envoyé un avion
militaire pour apporter de l'aide à
l'espagne et à l'italie
et c'est bien normal puisque ces pays
sont proches du point de vue les
intérêts en méditerranée et par ailleurs
la france et l'allemagne ont mis en
marche sur niant en musique le processus
un steak qui permet d'envoyer du
matériel médical à l'iran sans passer
par le dollar et sans passer par les
fourches caudines d'une autorisation
américaine puisque les américains ont
maintenu toutes leurs sanctions à
l'égard de l'iran et notamment dans ce
domaine ce qui évidemment un petit peu
surprenant dans les circonstances
actuelles fera sans doute aussi quelle
réflexion sur ce sujet un petit peu
lorsque la pandémie aura été maîtrisé
par ailleurs je voulais voter sur la
coopération internationale que le
secrétaire général de l'onu monsieur guy
thiriet sa lancée il ya quelques jours
un appel à un cessez le feu
généraliser partout dans le monde et que
finalement peut-être avec une certaine
surprise on peut constater que ça va
peut être marcher un certain nombre de
pays en syrie en libye mais aussi des
intervenants extérieurs comme les états
unis comme la turquie ont adhéré à cette
idée d'un cessez le feu généralisé pour
essayer de sauver des vies pour essayer
de sauver les populations et notamment
les personnes déplacées notamment tous
les gens qui vivent dans les camps de
réfugiés les uns sur les autres
il a lancé un deuxième à peine le prêt
de se mater général de l'onu en faveur
de l'afrique
il a dit qu'on allait avoir une
catastrophe programmée si on ne prenait
pas immédiatement des mesures
collectives pour aider l'afrique
l'afrique qui n'a pas les
infrastructures pour lutter contre une
pandémie de cette dimension
on voit bien que certains pays africains
commencent à être affectées
donc c'est aussi une priorité qui devra
être prise en compte et je pense que
puisque le président trump préside cette
année le g7 et il aura des initiatives à
prendre sans doute également en marge de
cette responsabilité
merci beaucoup clos de blanche maison
pour votre analyse je rappelle que vous
êtes expert en relations internationales